même si on se dit en se fracassant ce
travail en se poignardant sensu si vous
respectez pas le cerveau est mort qu'il
faut toujours essayer de recentrer sur
les sujets qui vous arrange et qui
peuvent déranger
ne cédez pas à la peur aux à quoi bon
ne cédez pas aux au grand relativisme
qui consisterait à dire tout se vaut
bah oui je suis confronté à un candidat
qui passe sa vie à une caricature est
totalement mes positions il faut qu'elle
donne tout ce débat ils ont tous qu'elle
en fasse partir avec rossel surgelés
morte fini mais c'est fini relève
surtout à un point derrière en revanche
si elle arrive à rester sur sa
simplicité avait au moins pourra
résister parce qu'en face on aura macron
extrêmement combatif pareil est mêlé le
maquereau le devant en aucun cas aucun
moment ni s'énerver et s'agacer la
l'humilier regardez on navire ne plus
partir sur des reproches ça c'est sûr
des reproches
vis-à-vis d'un quinquennat qui est
qu'elle va qu'elle va attaquer puisque
la dernière fois elle était face au
candidat macron aujourd'hui aller face
au président candidat macron ce qui
change forcément beaucoup de choses donc
très probablement on va avoir des
attaques sur sur le quinquennat elle
peut jouer sur tout ce qui s'est mal
passé pendant le quinquennat pour créer
justement cette espèce de défait de
rejet et en face on avoir quelqu'un qui
va devoir défendre son bilan et qui
amena il essayait de peut-être joué sur
toujours la décrédibilisation de la
candidate de l'extrême droite
quand ils entendent des choses
outrancière et bien qu'ils aillent se
renseigner par eux mêmes lire par eux
mêmes mon projet et ils s'apercevront
que moi mon objectif c'est la paire
l'intérieur le respect à l'extérieur
alors même que depuis cinq ans emmanuel
macron a très lourdement et gravement et
systématiquement fracturé la société
française table je pense que ce sera une
victoire aux points avec une marine le
pen qui est extrêmement dur à main
d'oeuvre et parce qu'elle ne va pas je
pense pas l'agresser elle va essayer de
s'adresser vous allez voir je pense pas
qu'elle me regarder les séries lyonnais
plutôt à la caméra mais c'est pas le
français vous qui l'ont regardé
attention ce personnes là pendant cinq
ans vous amener donc c'est un moment
important parce qu'il ya énormément de
français qui le regarde puis c'est un
moment important parce que je lis
tellement de d'incongruités sur mon
projet depuis quelques jours tellement
de caricatures voire même de fait que
news qu' il est extrêmement important
que je puisse avoir
un moment avec tous les français que ça
intéresse pour pouvoir rassurer tout le
monde et montrer que mon projet est en
même temps réfléchi crédible applicable
et qu'il correspond à ce que souhaitent
les français je le crois dans leur
majorité mais bon le maniema français
d'ici là tant s'attend à cela il ne va
pas l'agresser il a juste essayé de ne
pas le duo sur français pour exprimer
une idée simple le projet de marine le
pen d envoi ira dans le mur donc chacun
va marquer des points je pense que magna
pour comme il est président sortant bar
à [ __ ] parce qu'il a cette expérience
pense pas que de macron tombera dans un
piège dans le débat parce que c'est un
très bon débatteur c'est pas forcément
le plus grand orateur qui peut y avoir
il n'a pas forcément
la verve par exemple que peut avoir un
jean luc mélenchon mais il est très très
bon débatteur il n'y a pas de
difficultés sur l'exercice du débat mais
il rentre pas forcément dans un débat
violent c'est à dire qu'en général il
est assez bon aussi pour recentrer le
débat parce que finalement le débat à un
exercice d'un débat c'est simple il faut
surtout ne pas faire en sorte que la
personne qui soit en face de vous puisse
mener le débat qu'elle vous emmène sur
les sujets que vous ne voulez pas avoir
que vous ne voulez pas abordé qui vous
met mal à l'aise donc il faut toujours
essayer de recentrer sur les sujets qui
vous arrangent qui peuvent déranger
l'autre à consiste à sa préparer un
débat c'est on ne peut pas tout dire
donc eh bien il faut décider des sujets
ou à l'intérieur des sujets des éléments
qui nous apparaissent structurant pour
que l'ensemble des français puissent
comprendre quel est l'objectif de mon
projet et vous allez voir ce débat réel
extrêmement fort émotionnellement je
pense que c'est de très belles choses
j'espère des très beaux échanges
rappelez vous un grand débat nicolas
sarkozy ségolène royal il a respecté ses
coloris pour tout le débat cocasse et
les rues de chicago s'il vous plaît
qu'avez-vous je suis scandalisée de ce
que je viens d'entendre et les parents
et les familles qui disent en effet les
parents non je ne viens nous avons pas
du doigt vous sortez de vos goûts
beaucoup de facilités notamment
président de la république c'est
quelqu'un qui a des responsabilités
lourdes très lourdes savait que la
contrainte se fracasser comme l époque
jusqu'à avec mitterand moroy un bol de
paul ricoeur ça c'était un ko technique
terroir revenus des années après on
rappeler 9 du passé l'homme du passif
puisqu'il faut que les clubs du passé je
vous ai classique auront emballé c'est
pesé ça c'était l'époque où les français
attendent et le chaos maintenant les
carreaux mois présidence takao mois
président de la république je ne serai
pas le chef de la majorité - président
de la république je ne traiterai pas mon
premier une liste de collaborateurs
trois présidents bourg près d'hambourg
et il n'a pas vu venir là je ne pense
pas ça va se passer comme ça je pense
que marine le pen gamme aura peu de feu
de peu de latitude bizarrement aimé les
maquereaux va pourtant se montrer très
dans la démonstration dans l'ouverture
en sourire et dans l'optimisme marine le
pen elle sera à sa patrie mais quand
même le p6000 mais le déclic